for so many kids summer camp offers a
welcome escape but campers at one
program in Maine are getting away from
more than what most of us have ever had
to deal with Don Dahler had the chance
to visit this special program and talk
to some of those being helped by it at
the serene campus of Colby College in
Waterville Maine a group of resilient
kids got together for a unique camp
experience filled with bonding and
healing just being here and being able
to actually talk to people who
understand us was so good and just was
it helped me a lot to click with what I
think Astrid who asked us not to use her
last name went through a traumatic
experience when she was just 12 years
old her sister was among the 69 young
adults who were killed and a terror
attack at a camp in Norway in 2011
everything was just like so surreal and
it took me like I hear to actually
believe it so I just like walked around
thinking I would see her at every corner
at my school and stuff like that so I
didn't believe that people were there to
mourn her and like to be there first
because we lost her because I just
thought thought she was away yeah and do
you remember feeling that people just
couldn't understand what it felt like
yeah I remember so many people trying to
say the right words and me just thinking
was rude because they didn't understand
what I've been through
but when Astrid first came to the
project common bond summer camp three
years ago she remembers feeling relieved
that's because this week-long program is
for young adults who have lost a family
member in terrorist attacks violent
extremism or war this is actually my
second year at PCV like 16 year old
patch McMahon who wasn't yet born when
his father died on September 11th 2001
coming here I still have that empty spot
in my heart of having like a biological
father and some that like looks like me
and acts like me would be nice and like
since an early age I always like missed
that part of me and that's the hardest
thing
the camp has been around since 2008 and
has helped more than 700 teenagers from
28 nations learn to cope with loss the
program was created by twos days
children a non-profit founded to help
the thousands of kids who lost a parent
on 9/11 executive director Terry Sears
says as the years passed and a new
generation went off to war the
organization evolved we knew that you
know as people were running out of the
building there were nine eleven
responders running towards the buildings
and people signing up in the recruitment
centers and so many of the military
families that we now serve as gold star
families or families of the Fallen are
people that signed up because of 9/11 so
we look at them as also Tuesday's
children and as tragedies have continued
to unfold Sears says her organization
has stepped in we share our lessons
learned at Tuesday's children working
with victims for the last 17 plus years
because not only have we worked in 911
we've also helped communities like
Newtown and the Sandy Hook schools we
are currently working with parkland and
Orlando and other communities that have
suffered violence and and why we do that
is because we have lessons to share it's
part of the idea not only that they can
have a good life beyond the tragedy that
happened to them but that they can
actually take action to help make the
world a better place yeah they call it
post-traumatic growth that's what the
mental health specialists call it and
when someone kind of sees a vision to
actually do something with tremendous
meaning that is connected to their loss
I mean the energy and recovery is a
billion-fold because they just they know
it they know this is their life's
journey that recovery begins in the
winter when participants learn about
conflict resolution and peace building
so let's turn to the person next to and
I want you to talk about we think this
quote means and continues in the summer
when the kids take part in therapeutic
arts
group sessions and listen to
motivational speakers for some change in
perspective in the end it's all about
offering teams like hatch and Astrid a
chance to feel normal again does this
teach you that it's okay to have fun I
like this is one of the places I'm the
most happy and I think that's look so
weird to say we're all hey because we've
lost someone this is kind of a silver
lining of my loss like having people
that understand you're just like having
so much fun with people who've been
through the same as you've been - yeah
for CBS this morning Saturday Don Dahler
Waterville Maine such an interesting
notion that astro brings up there this
silver lining of loss and this whole
idea of post-traumatic growth you know
that there's good that can come from all
that pain when you can harness that it's
so sad that we need something like this
yeah but it's so good they have this
nice yeah you can't imagine how
tremendously comforting that must be
because just talking about it they must
speak a different language because of
the nature of their loss